ce qu'il faut savoir c'est donc le 1er
avril il y avait donc une enquête par un
procès parce que jeane manson a accusé
colline berry de diffamation suite aux
accusations d'une personne de télex
forme de chaleur c'est l'ex femme de
richard berry qui étaient avec lui entre
4 1984 et 1986 pendant périodes pendant
lesquelles les faits présumés se
seraient déroulés et pendant lesquelles
colline berry accuse jeane manson et
richard berry de viol et d'agression
sexuelle sur mineur voilà et donc j'ai
eu jane manson accusé attaqué colline
pour diffamation et là les choses ont
dégénéré parce que dans cette famille ce
toute cette histoire remue énormément de
choses et énormément de passion et il ya
un gros contentieux notamment entre
collines et l'actuelle femme de richard
berry à savoir pascal gorge tu sais pas
salon alors ce qui s'est passé c'est que
d'abord pendant le procès l'avocate de
qu il n'y a pas été de main morte
collinet l'adea roadie toutes les
accusations qu'elle qu'elle a dressés à
son père et à ma et à jeane manson comme
quoi voilà il y avait eu il l'avait
embrassée sur la bouche y avait le
fameux jeu de l' orchestre ou richard
aurait comparé son sexe à celui d'une
trompette d'une flûte ou sa venue dans
un lit sous les yeux de collinée avec
jeane manson à côté et la l'avocate pour
corroborer les faits les accusations de
colline a commencé à attaquer jane
manson a lui parlé notamment de
de
l'organisation dont elle était drôle de
la sec dont elle faisait partie
les enfants de dieu qui a été accusé
notamment de pédophilie elle lui a sorti
également des photos nues d'elle à
l'époque pour montrer à quel point elle
avait des moeurs légères et des moeurs
sexuelles très libérée et là au départ
jeane manson à commence à rigoler un peu
à se moquer et puis c'est parti en
cacahuète est là elle a dit que coline
de toute façon par toute la famille
depuis qu'elle avait dix ans était la
mito de la famille est là pascal louage
l'actuelle femme de richard berry s'est
jeté sur collines et la gifle et voilà
s'il faut savoir c'est que entre entre
pascal et coline ya déjà beaucoup de
choses qui se sont passées ce que ce qui
explique notamment pascal sait que
coline est très jalouse d'elle ce que
notamment elles sont tombées enceintes
en même temps et ça colle et lui a
reproché à hull a aussi reproché de
l'avoir coupée de son père d'avoir
privilégié ses enfants elle enfin il ya
vraiment voilà il ya vraiment beaucoup
de choses et pascal ou agent fait
l'accusent de de faire ça justement pour
lui porter préjudice à elles jugent ils
l'audience a été extrêmement tangage à
avec ça avait
l'audience a effectivement tendue sa vie
en rose à 9h jusqu'à 21h et sert 20
heures que la gifle s'est produite et il
faut savoir que dans la famille c'est de
plus en plus cristallisé et violent
puisque et une enquête préliminaire mais
par exemple richard berry qui étaient là
au procès n'a toujours pas été entendu
comment ils ont profité de l'audience
pour l'avait effectivement leur linge
sale en famille dire tout ce qu'ils ont
sur le coeur et donc c'est très très
violent entre eux c'est aller jusqu'à
cette gifle alors pascal louage
explique un moment qu'elle a été insulté
c'est pour ça qu'elle a répliqué par une
chips qui n'est pas excusable